the guitarist from The Offspring has me
blocked the very first song I ever
learned how to play on the guitar was
the kids aren't all right written by
this man and he has blocked me on
Twitter truly a day for me to behold is
your cover that bad uh he's uh he
probably blocked me because you know I'm
friends and play music with their old
drummer who they crapped all over
because they're nasty evil people and uh
man you know what I will say one thing
that frustrates me
is that there's a lot of secrets about
celebrities that if people only knew but
this guy from my understanding is lying
about everything really
I can't say much more because not my
place to say and that bothers me but
until someone comes out and comes on the
record about the band and about their
actual
um
let's just say about the truth there's
not much more I can say